- Hi, everyone.
Sal here from Khan Academy,
welcome to the homeroom live stream.
We had a little bit of a
hiatus, but now we are back.
I had a torn calf and other
things, but I'm almost
fully recuperated, but
thanks for joining me.
We have a really exciting
conversation today
with Katy Knight, head of
the Siegel Family Endowment.
But before we start that I'll give some
of my standard announcements.
First, a reminder that Khan
Academy is a not-for-profit
organization, that we
can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making a donation
to at khanacademy.org/donate.
Also wanna give a special shout
out to several organizations
that stepped up when they
realized that not only
was the world leaning on Khan Academy,
as we had mass school closures,
but Khan Academy's costs had
gone up and we were already
running into deficit even before that.
So special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly and Novartis
for helping us fill some
of that gap, but we still need more help.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about seeing if
you can help out in some way.
And then last but not
least, I wanna remind folks
about Homeroom with Sal, the podcast,
which is essentially a version
of what you're seeing right
now, where we're taking kind
of the best of our live stream
and putting it in a format
that you can experience
in your car without
running into other cars.
So check that out, wherever
you get your podcasts.
So with that, I'm excited to
introduce Katy, Katy Knight,
Executive Director of the
Siegel Family Endowment.
Good to see you, Katy.
- It's good to see you too.
Thanks for having me.
- So maybe a good place to start is,
what is a family endowment and what is
the Siegel Family Endowment in particular?
What's its focus?
What does it do?
What's the work of it?
- Yeah, that's a really good question.
So endowment for us, for
some people this is not true,
but for us is really just
a fancy replacement word
for foundation because someone
else had already established
a Siegel Family foundation.
And so David, (indistinct).
- Oh really,
I didn't know that.
- The chairman and my boss (indistinct)
and really we're a foundation,
a private foundation.
So that means we give away money,
but also engage in other activities.
We support research, we support
really great non-profits
like Khan Academy that are
doing really important work
out in the world.
But what we really try to do,
that's a little bit different
because we're smaller foundation
and a little bit newer
on the scene is also trying to think about
how we can change conversations.
How we can do some thought leadership
and really are focused on
reframing questions and ideas.
So not just writing a
check and sitting back
and hoping for the best,
but really thinking
about how we can help
change the conversation
and help people think about the impact
of technology on society,
which is our focus,
in a different way.
And so, that is both the positive impact
and the sometimes negative
impact of tech on society.
And we're looking at
both sides of the coin
and trying to figure out ways
to leverage tech for good
and also to help mitigate
some of the downsides
that have come.
- Yeah, and as you mentioned,
the Siegel Family Endowment
is a longtime major
funder of Khan Academy.
So everyone watching who enjoys
Khan Academy's existence,
please think Katy and David,
who's family endowment.
This isn't, I'm not saying
this cause you're in the room.
I would say this, even if you weren't
in the video conference
or whatever we're doing.
But maybe a good place
to is to double click
on what you just said,
that your focus is on tech
and it's mitigating, its
negative implications
and promoting its positive.
What are some of those things?
What are some of the things
that you y'all are worried about
that you have to actively
make sure that tech
doesn't go bad, so to speak.
And then what are the things
that you could promote
where the tech could be a force for good.
- Yeah, so I think we've
seen a lot in terms
of misinformation or
disinformation on the internet,
where tech and social media platforms,
communication platforms
can be used for bad,
where you have micro-targeting,
where you can really
do things in the darkness,
the sort of underbelly of tech
and the way that advertising
and conversation targeting
can work is really something
that we've been looking at
for a long time.
And lots of people are looking
at this from different angles
from academic researchers to
institutions that are trying
to combat and come up
with practical solutions
for this stuff.
So that's just one example.
I think there are other economic examples
of how tech can and has accelerated some
of the divide in the country.
When you think about people
who are benefiting the most
from tech companies and those who aren't.
So we look at all of
those things holistically
and think about how they
intersect and how we can try
to help soften the steep differences
and how we can help change
some of that for the better.
I think the flip side of that,
where you can leverage tech
for good is moments like
this, where we're able
to have these conversations,
share with people new ideas,
new concepts, online, speak
to really broad audiences
around the world, connect and share.
Where you have things like
Khan, where people can learn
outside of the traditional
classroom setting
and really have access
to educational resources
that are really powerful.
And even the same communication
platforms I was talking
about before that have been used for harm,
have also done a lot of good for people
who have found community
online where maybe
they didn't have it in person.
- Yeah, and I wanna dig more into that.
I know you've just
published this white paper
on how infrastructure
influences everything,
but on that first part
around tech, I am fascinated.
I don't think anyone has some
obvious good solutions here,
but you mentioned the
micro-targeting and social media
and the conversations
that I've been a part of,
the social media and its impact
on especially young people
and their self perception.
And could it drive anxiety and depression,
but there's also social
media for polarizing us
where you only get what
you, and maybe you engage
even deeper in something that
polarizes you and further.
Do you all have any, are
y'all talking to some people
that you think have good
solutions who can thread
that needle between free
speech, but not speech
that does ... it's a
really difficult question.
- Yeah, it is a really difficult question.
And I think, we have
friends and colleagues
at research institutions like
the Stanford has a project
in their philanthropy
and civil society center
that's about digital civil society.
And some of the researchers
who are associated with that
are looking at these questions.
I think there are no easy answers.
One of the things that I
default to often that I think
is really important to talk
about, is transparency.
So I think human beings we're
smarter than maybe the tech
and social media platforms
wanna give us credit for.
And if you know that you're
being shown search results,
for example, that are aligned
with one point of view
that an algorithm thinks
is your point of view,
or if you know that you're being targeted
by a specific advertising.
I think that knowledge
can be really powerful
in terms of helping you
understand the context
around the information that you're seeing
and helping you think
differently about whether or not
it's true and verifiable.
We have a really wide range
of resources on the internet
and some of them are more
fact-checked than others.
So I think that transparency
and context can do a lot
to help combat some of that polarization
misinformation space.
And I think that's one of
the places where practical
solutions are being experimented
with, really interestingly.
- No, I really liked that.
Actually I haven't heard that
before, but you're right.
If at all you told me is
like, "Hey, because you are
a middle-aged man, who's into
alien conspiracy theories.
We are now going to give you this."
I think that is my profile (laughs)
- (indistinct) and we're
gonna dig into that.
- Middle-aged man who likes to read about
alien conspiracy theories.
Therefore here's your top search results.
And I'm like, wait, I'm
not a middle aged man.
And no, I am. (laughs)
I just turned 44 on Sunday.
So I've come to terms with my--
- Happy birthday.
- I still can't get over
the fact that 44 plus 16 is 60.
I know I'm known for teaching math,
but I keep thinking I'm
doing the math wrong,
but anyway, back to the subject.
So on this notion of
infrastructure obviously
where's technical infrastructure
or digital infrastructure
is a piece, and this is what you analyze
in your white paper.
But maybe the first question
is why did y'all decide
to write a white paper on infrastructure
and what were kind of the big ahas?
- Yeah, so a few things I
will say that it started
because I am an infrastructure nerd.
David is an infrastructure nerd.
We just have always
connected on questions of,
and thoughts about infrastructure.
I think--
- I've never met
anyone who's called themselves
an infrastructure nerd.
So you get points just for that.
- I've met a lot of them.
- And you know someone else
who was an infrastructure.
I'm probably an infrastructure nerd too.
Now that I know that it's a thing.
- Yeah, now that you know it's a thing,
you are definitely an infrastructure nerd.
It's impossible not to be, I think once
you actually dig into it.
Growing up in New York
city, you take the subways
and when you started to ask questions,
well, why is this train later?
What's happening over here
and what what's going on
with these tracks?
It gets fascinating really quickly.
And that's just the physical
infrastructure piece.
And so at first we just started talking
about how a foundation
like ours could be a part
of the conversation about infrastructure.
And as we were digging in
more and more on the topic,
we had this work on digital infrastructure
happening almost separately,
where we were thinking
about things like the
open source community,
open learning platforms,
which is where we put
our Khan Academy relationship
in open learning.
And started to see these intersections,
the really obvious one is broadband access
as sort of a physical
infrastructure asset.
And your ability to access something
like an open learning platform.
And so we started to talk and
think just a little bigger
and a little wider about what
infrastructure could mean.
And that's what the first big aha was,
it was that infrastructure
had to be more than
just about the bridges, the
roads, that really this triangle
of physical, digital and
social infrastructure.
That's how we need to be
thinking about the assets
that we should be investing in.
The things that we should care about.
The things that the government
should be safeguarding,
our physical, digital, and
social assets that are underlying
all of our society and
keeping us functional.
- This is fascinating.
And I wanna remind everyone watching,
feel free to put questions
on YouTube and Facebook
and our team will surface
it to myself and Katy
and ask really about anything
about infrastructure,
about endowments, about
... I'm going to ask Katy
a little bit about how she even
found herself in this role.
So really ask both me and
Katy anything y'all want,
but just double clicking on that Katy,
I think most of us are
familiar with physical
infrastructure, those are
roads and bridges and dams
and power lines and things like that.
And I think we can imagine
digital infrastructure,
which is related to
physical infrastructure,
which is, I guess you could
debate whether it's physical
or digital, but it's having
internet connectivity
or at least having a device
or maybe having support
for using that device.
What is social infrastructure?
- Yeah, so social infrastructure is really
a little bit more intangible.
You're thinking about the
networks that you're a part of,
the relationships that you
have with other people.
The one idea that I've talked
about with people before is,
the notion that perhaps access
to childcare for example,
is infrastructure because if
you're a parent as you are
so you know that in order to work,
you need someone to help
take care of your kids.
And so how people are able
to contribute to the economy
and be a part of that is really important
to the nation's health and prosperity.
So thinking about social
infrastructure as an element
that matters, I think it
is a little bit trickier
and can vary also depending on
the community that you're in.
So, for some people having access to space
where you can, coworking
space where entrepreneurship
and a culture of
entrepreneurship is being built,
can help them launch new
businesses and contribute
to their local economy.
We've invested in some work
in rural America related
to helping create space and
cultures of entrepreneurship
to kind of revive economies.
So really it can vary.
You can see in this
illustration that we talk
about the digital economy,
we talk about libraries.
Libraries are a place where
I think that physical,
digital and social
infrastructure really intersect
where you get both the access
to tech, the physical space,
where you have information,
knowledge, and also
it's opportunities to
take classes, to maybe
learn a new language, to
access information about how
to get online and how
to use new technology.
All of that can happen at
a library, which was why
they're one of our big
examples in the paper
and a space for really exciting new ideas.
I think, about what social infrastructure
and what infrastructure in
communities can look like.
- Now that you've named
social infrastructure.
I now realize not only am
I an infrastructure nerd,
I think I'm a social infrastructure nerd,
because I spend a lot of
time thinking about maybe
how do we social engineer?
I mean, even in our direct
life, which obviously
is more of a personal thing,
like how do we make sure
we have deeper friendships?
How do we make sure our kids
have places they can go to?
How do you architect
that on a larger scale?
Super, super fascinating.
What are your big takeaways?
Like what part of infrastructure
are we doing well as a society?
Are there examples of other
countries that are doing a
better job where if y'all
were emperor of the universe,
where would you invest?
How would you invest that?
- I think on many fronts,
we're not doing so well.
So even on the physical
infrastructure front,
we've seen, the American
society of civil engineers
puts out a report card on how
our infrastructure is doing.
They gave us a D plus,
which was not a great grade.
And that's before you
consider these additional
dimensions we have.
That being said, in their bright spots,
there are towns and cities
with access to fiber,
high speed internet.
There are places where the
library systems are doing
an incredible job with reinforcing
the social infrastructure
and coming into the new century
with these opportunities,
for people to get online and
to learn how to do things that
will help them get jobs and be a part
of this new innovation economy.
I think overall, we should
be thinking differently
about how we spend the
dollars that we have
to build new things and
to fix the old things.
We haven't done a great
job of maintenance,
ongoing maintenance, but
we should be investing
with an eye toward how
any dollar that we spend
should have a payoff on all three fronts,
not just one.
And so I'm not going to
say that we shouldn't
spend more money.
I think we do need to spend more money.
It happens at the state and
local and federal levels,
but that we could also spend
the same amount of money
and probably do a better job of it.
If we looked at things and
thought about the payoff
and also brought people to
the table who represented
all three sides of the triangle.
- Yeah, and to your point,
sometimes the same effort
can actually hit all three sides.
If it's thought out, what's
your sense of why we have un ...
I mean, even just on
physical infrastructure,
it feels like that's even like,
it shouldn't be a political issue.
I don't think anyone argues
with better roads, safe bridges,
good utility infrastructure, et cetera.
Cause you suffer, it's very
apparent when it's bad.
It's very apparent when bad things happen
or when power lines go
down and things like that.
Why do we have this D grade right now?
- I think it's a few
things, our infrastructure
in the US especially
is super decentralized.
So more spending, more
funding for infrastructure
comes from the state and local level
than the federal government,
even though people think about,
the federal government, when
you think about something
as big as infrastructure,
but actually even
in the physical sense most
highways are actually owned
at the state level, not
at the federal level,
even though lots of federal
investment went into creating
the highway system and interstates
and that sort of thing.
We are not necessarily
thinking about the future
when we make infrastructure
investments either.
So we are looking to fix
the immediate problems
right in front of us,
but not thinking about
the future uses and future needs.
So by the time you can get
an infrastructure project
through the bureaucracy, it
can often already be outdated
before things even start being built.
And I think anything that
involves spending, unfortunately,
becomes a political issue, of course.
And again, if we can
think differently about
how to spend smartly, we might all,
I think everyone loves a
deal, maybe deals and bargains
are not necessarily political.
So if we can make the case
that like you're getting
a really good deal by
investing in infrastructure
and looking at it through
these three lenses,
then perhaps we could get
people to spend more money
or invest differently without
it becoming a political issue.
- Yeah, the argument with any investment,
including infrastructures,
it should have some return.
If you build a bridge, people
have a shorter commute time,
it'll increase commerce,
and that will generate even,
not only more productivity,
which will generate
more tax revenue, which you can use to pay
for more infrastructure.
There's a question here and it's related
to what I just asked you.
It's from YouTube, Hasset Gassess.
Why do we think America's
infrastructure is worse
than say Germany's
infrastructure, first of all,
do you have a sense of
something like that true?
And it feels like a
very comparable country.
Is it based on how it's structured
and the decentralized nature?
Is it something is just,
we're different than Germans
in how much we care about our
roads and bridges and things.
- Yeah, I think there are
a lot of potential answers
to that question, and I'm
sure that there are people
who will agree and disagree
with my point of view on it.
I think it's a combination
of all those things.
The US is vast, even though
I think we have comparables
in other countries like
Germany or even places in Asia
like Japan or China where
they've done, I think a good job
building infrastructure,
physical infrastructure.
We also do have this really
different decentralized system.
And we do have, I think, a
different approach in terms
of how we think about whose responsibility
is to take care of these
things and how quickly
we're able to move and to gain
the partnership and create
the opportunity for
new things to be built.
I think we haven't made
it as much of a priority
to invest in our infrastructure in the US
as some other places have.
- Hmm.
And it's a related question from Facebook,
Christabell Mendoza asks,
which cities in the US
would be good models at
successfully encompass
physical, social, and
digital infrastructure?
- That's a really good question.
And I'm hoping that as
part of what we're doing
with talking about this
paper out in the world,
that people will share more
examples with us of where
they've seen really
great things happening,
whether that's, in a city,
state, or even just a town
think there are really
good examples at all levels
and all sizes of how infrastructure,
of these three pieces
of infrastructure can come
together, work better together.
We have some good examples
in the white paper of places
like Kansas city that have
really leveraged their access
to fiber internet to
create an opportunities,
that's coming back to
that libraries as example,
we were talking about.
Some of the towns that we work
with through our rural work.
I'm not gonna name them because
there are now over a dozen
and I don't wanna miss any,
but there are a few called out
also in the paper, or if you
scroll through the website,
which I think the link is
somewhere on the bottom
of the screen, you can click
through some of the map
that we have, which calls
out a few, a handful of towns
where we've invested
that are doing a good job
with this physical,
digital, social framework.
- Are most of the examples,
you've given one example
of fiber optic, high
bandwidth, that's both physical
someone has to dig up
and lay down that fiber,
but that's obviously digital
infrastructure as well.
And then you make it available
in schools and libraries,
and then the community can benefit.
And they're having kind
of a social connection,
which is a social infrastructure.
Are there other examples beyond,
and there's a question here
from Suzanna Garcia Dominguez.
Hi Katy, what is the
best optimization idea
you have heard about infrastructure?
Is it more of this
library flavor of things
with high speed broadband?
Are there other cool ideas you
all have been thinking about?
- I think they're, well,
we'd love to hear cool ideas
from all over.
So there's a place both on the website,
but also our emails are accessible.
So we're always happy to
hear pie in the sky ideas
for optimization here.
I think a lot of what stands
out is related to this
internet access, just
because, especially right now,
especially in the
context of this pandemic,
we've seen that be so important.
And we've seen that there
still such an incredible divide
in the country in terms of
who has strong internet access
and who doesn't.
And I think that's why
so many of the examples
that are top of mind for me right now,
and that feel, innovative and
important are related to that.
But I think we're really
open to new ideas for how
to optimize the using the
framework and want to experiment
and find places that are
interested in just taking a chance
on this idea and
implementing some new things.
- I've been talking to a lot
of folks lately and I said,
this COVID situation with
school closures is not good.
It's a suboptimal, but if
there's a silver lining,
it's that, there's more energy than ever,
in trying to close the digital divide.
Are you all seeing that?
And on a scale of one to 10,
how hopeful are you that
in the next five years,
the digital divide at
home, at least in the US
is closed a good bit.
- I'm really hopeful about that.
I think we have seen not
just energy and enthusiasm
around closing the digital
divide more than ever.
We've also seen, I think, renewed interest
from the private sector
in helping us get there,
which is one of the things that
we talked about in the paper
a bit too, is, we need to think
beyond just the government
has money and should invest here.
But thinking about how the private sector,
how the social sector,
the philanthropic sector,
non-profit world, that I'm a
part of, everyone contributes
to infrastructure, both
in terms of the capital,
the money that we're spending,
but also just the thoughts
and the governance of infrastructure
and how we shape it moving forward.
So I think that is something
I'm super hopeful about,
in terms of closing digital divide.
I think we have a long way to go
and we have to keep pushing,
even if we get back to
a place where school's
more in person than it has been,
even if we're able to
work from offices again,
this still matters.
It's not just, if you
have to do school on zoom,
that you should be worried
about the digital divide.
It matters, if you're
trying to do homework
at the end of the day, it
matters for all sorts of reasons.
So I think if we can maintain this energy
that we all have around
making sure that more people
have access, I feel really
hopeful that we can solve
this problem because we
actually know how to solve it.
Like you bring the access to
the people, like you said,
you dig the holes and
you lay the fiber cable,
you do those things and
we can get access to folks
who need it.
- Yeah, and there's other
whole things I'm hopeful of,
obviously the whole Starlink project,
Elon Musk's micro satellites
that he's gonna pull out
that he's already putting into orbit,
that'll give us internet
access almost anywhere.
Yeah, good to hear that
you're a similarly hopeful
because it does feel
like clean drinking water
or just basic shelter
in the decades to come.
Maybe in the remaining time,
I do always like to ask,
we have sometimes a lot
of young people watching.
And I remember when I was a young person,
I would always wonder, how do
you ... you know of certain
careers, doctors, lawyers,
engineers, and you can go
to certain schools and
eventually end up being one
of those professions, but
there's clearly many other jobs
in the world that have
less clear career tracks,
like being the executive
director of a family foundation.
How did you, did you
see yourself doing this?
What did you think you were going to do?
And how did you end up in this role?
- Yeah, it's sort of a funny story.
And I'll try to tell you
the abridged version,
but when I was in high
school and in college,
in my sort of early years of college,
I thought that I wanted to
work in the non-profit sector.
I thought that I wanted
to start a non-profit.
And then I learned that
there's too many non-profits
and you probably don't
need to start a non-profit
of your own, but maybe
you could go work in one.
And then I learned about
philanthropy and I said,
oh, well, better to sit on
the other side of the table,
sounds good to give
away money for a living.
And I really quickly
learned that there was not
a clear career path into philanthropy
that it's very bespoke.
It depends a lot on the different
foundations individually,
and that there are not a ton
of entry level positions.
So I sort of forgot about it.
I put it to the side and I said,
maybe I'll get there one day.
Until then I'll go back
to my idea of working
in the non-profit sector.
And I did work in a
non-profit, I went to school
in Philadelphia and I
lived there for a few years
after I graduated.
I worked at a very cool
non-profit there that actually
has a giant puppet park theater,
but also social activism,
non-profit called spiral Q and--
- A giant puppet park theater.
When you're just a giant
puppet, I was like,
what more is that?
But now I think I understand it.
It's a giant puppet.
- (indistinct)
They are invested in social activism
and it started a long time ago as just,
they would build these giant puppets
and their protest puppets.
And I can share a link later with anyone
who's actually curious about
this, but it was a great time.
And then there's little bit of luck.
I happened to get a job at
Google when they were launching
Google plus because they thought
there were some interesting
use cases for the non-profit sector.
And I had that experience.
And then while I was at Google,
I took this winding path
through doing many things
with the organization.
One of those things was
corporate social responsibility,
community engagement work.
And that took me down a
interesting journey of learning
what it was like to
connect with the community
as a representative of the company.
Got me some experience with
giving money away for a living.
And that then took me to David's company.
And then eventually
David and I just realized
that we had things in common
and thought the same way.
And I started to work with, what was then
very small team of SFE.
And it just so happened
that the timing was right.
And I wound up taking a
job working just directly
with David on the philanthropy.
And just last year actually
became the executive director
after we had some changes.
So I think that's probably
not a helpful answer
if you're trying to launch
a career in philanthropy.
I will say two things, one
a little controversial,
not going to graduate
school actually turned out
to be really great for my career.
I may still go to graduate
school one day who knows,
with this online world, I
may be able to swing it,
but I always really wanted
to go to grad school,
but could never decide
what I would focus on.
Cause I'm just all over the place
and think about different
things every hour.
But not going to graduate
school and not focusing,
made me a little more adaptable.
And so I would pick up any
opportunity and look at it
as a chance to learn something
and try it on for size.
And that took me to a
really interesting place
in my career.
And the other thing is just,
I was lucky and timing played
a big role and I think timing
and luck are what they are,
but you have to, again, be
open to the opportunity,
you have to be trying
to make the timing work.
So consider anything that
comes your way as a chance
to do something different
and see where it takes you.
And you may end up running a foundation.
- Yeah, I'm surprised that you say
you like giving money away.
I think asking for money is so much fun.
(indistinct)
It's actually fun.
- I'm not very good at that either.
I'm not great at asking for money.
- No asking for money is not an, yeah,
you gotta ruffle up your
hair, have your puppy,
dog eyes and (laughs)
- (indistinct) for those people though.
Everyone should give
money to Khan Academy.
- I agree with you, I agree.
That's a really good point.
I agree with you.
Very high social return on investment.
The last question, and
it's related to the one
we just talked about from
YouTube Bashar Ostara says,
what are some challenges you think
the next generation will face?
And I'll just broaden it.
You're someone that is a young person.
You're already thinking,
I wanna do something
that has some social impact,
do good for the world.
I think most young people
are in that same frame,
but there's like, how do I do?
What do you think are the,
any problem is an opportunity.
So what do you think are some of the ones
that they should start thinking about?
- Yeah, I know that so many
young and younger people
are thinking about this
already, but climate
and climate change are so important for us
to be thinking about.
We, older people should
also be doing a better job
tackling climate change,
but I think there's so much
opportunity to anything from
inventing new technologies,
to starting new non-profits
or social movements
related to that.
Like that work is so important and we have
to solve these problems.
There's no choice, but to solve them.
So I think that's one
that I would call out.
But coming back to some of the stuff
we were talking about earlier,
I think, thinking about how
tech can be used for good
is not just a non-profit sector issue.
It's an issue for anyone,
whether you're an academic,
whether you're doing private sector work,
no matter what, you can
be looking at the world
and thinking how can
what I'm doing contribute
to solving problems rather
than creating more problems?
I think if we did more of that,
no matter what we were doing,
we would all be better for it.
- Well, that's great advice.
And I can't imagine, yeah,
it's a very existential issue
of climate change.
So that's a good one to
highlight, but there's many more.
What Katy, whenever we
have these conversations
the time always go by
faster than I expect,
but thank you so much for joining.
This was a real treat.
- Yeah, thank you.
- And thank you for your
support over the years.
I'm not joking.
It's been a big part of
what allows Khan Academy
to be Khan Academy.
- Well, thank you.
Thank you for all that you do.
I still watch Khan Academy
videos when I need to learn
something new or refresh my memory.
So appreciate your work
in more ways than one
on a personal level and what
you're doing for the world.
And this was fun.
It's always fun to talk to you,
but also great to talk also
to everyone else out there.
- Yeah, last time we met,
I remember that, this is all pre-COVID,
where we could go to a restaurant.
- To restaurants.
- I remember there was
like some cheese fries
that I was having like
self control issues with,
but anyway, thank you--
- You had come out
of a long trip you just needed sustenance.
It happened to be french fries.
- Yeah, my whole life is all
about discipline and like,
but then the levy breaks and anyway,
whole other conversation.
Thanks Katy.
- Thanks.
- Well, thanks everyone for joining us,
always a really fun conversation with Katy
and I actually hope we can
get David Siegel on well
from the Siegel Family Endowment
in the next several weeks.
But thanks everyone for
joining our next homeroom,
is gonna be tomorrow with Arne Duncan,
secretary of education in
the Obama Administration.
And he's a managing
partner at Chicago CRED.
He does really incredible
work with young people,
especially in Chicago.
So Arne Duncan, who I also
consider to be a good friend
and an all around good guy.
So I look forward to that
conversation tomorrow.
So thanks everyone for joining.
And I'll see you tomorrow
with secretary Duncan.
(theme sound)